a Sunday cruise on rampart Boulevard
dashcam video shows me driving north
soon turning deadly I pass Vegas drive
and then the white Mercedes SUV flies by
second later the 22 to 20/20 hande Jose
Escobedo dashboard camera recorded the
two cars speeding by him a minute later
plumes of black smoke rise from a crash
I saw the car in pieces at night
someone's got to be seriously injured
police say 22 month old Royce Jones died
his mother
Lauren Prussia is accused of driving 121
miles per hour in the Hyundai with him
while impaired a police report claims
the driver of the Mercedes was Cameron
Hubbard Jones the baby's father he
stated to officers both were speeding on
the road Russia is facing charges right
now and more may come there are in some
cases other charges that we could bring
district attorney Steve Wolfson says
this remains an open investigation not
revealing if his office may look at
Hubbard Jones as well
the police is still conducting
interviews and doing forensic work ups
and things like that
I'm aware of what the facts suggest as
to what the father and what his
involvement was at this point we're
focusing on the mother court records
show pressure having three traffic
violations - involving speed wolfson
must now consider all evidence as the
community mourns the untimely loss
Kristen Drummond 8 news now